[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
mm-hmm
welcome to 13 o'clock uh i'm tom
and i'm here with jenny and we're your
hosts
and this is our uh first episode and uh
today
we're going to talk about two things
we're going to talk about
a poltergeist case called the entity and
then later on we're going to talk about
uh some theories about the classic movie
the shiny
and uh okay jenny so
do you want to go ahead and start with
uh entity sure we can just
jump into it if you want to sure okay
let's do that all right so
uh what we're talking about is if you
didn't know in 1982
um a rather well-known movie came out
called the entity
and barbara hershey was in it and i
was based on a book by frank defalida
which came out in 1978 now this book was
actually based on a real
person it was based on a real case that
was investigated by the parapsychology
lab at ucla in 1974.
now the first thing the movie um
is actually fairly accurate up until it
gets to
the really stupid ending yeah and
um i'll say spoiler alert but uh spoiler
alert at the end of it
they set up uh basically a trap
using liquid helium to essentially
freeze
freeze of pulp the poltergeist yeah and
it works
and then it busts out and then it busts
out and all the skeptics are like oh i
guess you guys were right
and the parapsychologists are vindicated
now obviously
that did not happen in real life because
frozen ghosts are ridiculous
right so uh but
it was actually based on a real case and
it was investigated yeah
so we're actually kind of going to go
into the so we're going to talk about
the movie
and the cs we're going to talk about the
movie and the real case
um so basically the the woman in the
movie was named carla moran but that
uh that's not the real woman's name the
real woman's name is actually doris
bither it was not released until many
years later
yeah and not a lot is known of her early
life
because she was very um cagey about her
past with investigators because
apparently
she didn't really have that happy a life
leading up to that point
which makes you wonder which it does
yeah
and we'll kind of get into that at the
end after i've kind of
summarized but basically uh they think
she was born in the midwest somewhere
probably illinois
okay and uh this was she moved to
california with her family when she was
10. now her family
was supposedly upper middle class family
but they're very dysfunctional there are
rumors that her
parents were alcoholics possibly abusive
although i'm not sure if that's true now
she's dead now so she's not available
for
right right she's dead some of her
children are still alive but um
but she is she is not she's not with us
right okay so evidently after they moved
to california um
when she got into her teenage years uh
she and her parents
really started not seeing eye to eye
there were rumors that she
got into the occult she was very
rebellious what have you
and reportedly they disowned her so
she was kind of cast out on her own when
she was 16 or so
just getting into the occult thing
that's that's so stereotypical it makes
me wonder if that
that's actually true yeah i'm just i
don't know [ __ ]
probably just because so they could
blame her right
inspired by the exorcist oh it's always
the ouija boards
yeah things like that bringing those
demons yeah
so i don't know if that's the case but
anyway so anyway uh
so after she was cast out of her family
home
evidently um she ended up about as you
would expect uh she ended up with a lot
of abusive
boyfriends uh several pregnancies
she fell into the wrong hands yes
exactly and uh
as happens with the young girls that age
yeah
and by the time the she came to the
attention of parapsychologists they
uh she would not say how old she was but
she they said she appeared to be in her
mid-30s
she lived in culver city california at
the time uh she had four
children a 16 year old son a 13 year old
son
a 10 year old son and a six-year-old
daughter i believe these were all from
different fathers
she was a single mother at the time i
thought i think she did have a boyfriend
at some
point during this investigation she
wouldn't even say how old she was
no weird yeah i wonder why
come on couldn't be that well they said
i mean the
the guy that investigated he said she
was rather uncommunicative
okay but uh that's kind of as far as he
would go on that right
but here's the thing now like in the
movie
i actually didn't kind of believe this
because it seemed too coincidental when
i saw the movie um
how she met up with the parapsychologist
actually seemed like too
perfect to be true but evidently
according to her son and according to
uh dr barry taff who was the main guy
that investigated he said this is how it
happened
um doris bither was in a bookstore
in culver city just browsing around and
she heard
two men talking about the paranormal
okay and she approached them and said
hey
i have all this that sounds like what's
happening to me
and these two men happen to be dr barry
taff
and his colleague carrie gainer who were
from the parapsychology lab at ucla
now obviously you know they probably get
cranks walking up to them all the time
saying oh my god i have that paranormal
[ __ ] happening to me too
so at first they were just kind of like
yeah whatevs but um
you know she was very insistent and
when she told them now i think she told
them in the bookstore what the
uh most startling manifestation
of this phenomena was which was
essentially ghost rape
she claimed that these entities
which she believed they were outside
entities i don't know if she thought
they were demons
but she yeah but she thought they were
outside and they would
rape her or rather two of them would
hold her down while the third would rape
her
yeah i'd imagine i imagine they were
kind of like yeah sure
yeah so that's what i'm that's what i
mean
uh yeah so and i i'm actually i'm
writing a book about
um poltergeist phenomena in general i'm
kind of summarizing a bunch of cases and
talking about a bunch of theories and
stuff like that
and this i was what i was doing was i
was putting like all the cases into
themed chapters right you know ones that
caused fires or ones that made puddles
or whatever
and i wanted to write about this one so
i was going to do a whole chapter about
spirit rape essentially or
spectrophilia but here was the weird
thing
this really seems to be kind of the only
case i could find
through using my google foo yeah that um
that was this type of thing that was
rape that someone essentially
because spectrophilia that's actually a
fetishy thing like most of the people
that are into like ghost sex
are into it right so they're calling the
ghosts to have sex
exactly yeah so it's not so
it's not it's consensual in those cases
all the other ones i found were
evidently consensual and probably
crackpot saying yeah i [ __ ] a ghost
whatever yeah
but uh so this was the only case of like
spirit rape like i said
but she had a lot of visible bruises on
her body including
on her inner thighs and things of that
nature so finally she talked the
parapsychologist into visiting her house
now uh barry taff has written a report
of this i've read like kind of the
abstract and he
and an interview with him about it and i
think he's there's a youtube video yeah
like where he's talking he's the
character himself yeah he is
and um he said that when he first got to
the house which i've seen pictures of
the house it's not like a shack but it's
pretty dumpy i mean she was a single mom
she was living there with her four kids
look like lower middle class
california a little bungalow type yeah
as it would
now uh barry taft said that the family
were quote unquote living in their own
filth
yeah that that brings images to mind
right so i'm not really sure if we're
talking about
like a hoarder situation like i said and
i think we we said this before about the
the woman on hoarders with the poop in
the bag that made the floor collapse
i don't know if it was that bad it
didn't look that bad from the video
footage yeah
i think it was just kind of a case but
being messy or yeah you know having old
pizza boxes and
garbage did not take garbage out yeah
exactly so i think it was something like
that
that maybe white trash living right
which
you know we assume we weren't there yeah
so so they get to the house and
her four children are willing to
corroborate
her story particularly the older two
sons um
and all the children said that they had
witnessed strange things happening at
home things moving around
um doris and i believe one of the
children
also said that sometimes they would be
walking around the house and they would
it would feel like they would run into
what what seemed to be an invisible
person
and they'd run into an invisible person
that actually hit something
yeah they'd feel it right this is what
they claim yeah
so and also the older son
said that uh his bedroom shared a wall
with his mothers and he said he often
heard her screaming in the next room
heard her being thrown around
moaning yes yeah
oh this poor woman so um kids
i know we don't we don't mean to make we
don't know where you know it might be
really shitty i don't know what it's
like to be raped by a ghost
you know so um and
the the son also said that he had seen
his mother being attacked in this way
and that he had tried to intervene
and he had been thrown back against a
wall
by an unseen force yes all right
so the fact that the kids were willing
to corroborate the story
made the parapsychologist think well
maybe we'll look into this a little bit
more so they arranged to have
other researchers from the university
come to the house now they were there
for an investigation over
about a 10-week period and
evidently i mean they recorded some
pretty startling things no one saw
any of the spirit rape happening in
front of their faces all right
however many of the researchers claimed
that what they would do was um because
the entity seemed to respond
to doris they would have her sit in her
room
and swear or like try to provoke
the entity in some way to get it to
manifest itself
okay so they said when she did this
they would all clearly see a green
light emanating kind of from thin air
and they said this light was dimensional
meaning you could see all the way around
it so it wasn't just like reflected on
the wall or what have you
all right they said it also seemed to
respond
to their voices to their questions as
though it was intelligent like
you know it would brighten when they
would ask it something or something like
that how many people would see this at a
time
dude do you have that i'm not super sure
like there were
about 30 people in and out of the
investigation like
and if you can see some of the photos um
and they're on they're online somewhere
i can probably put them on the youtube
video but um
you can see from the pictures that there
are many people like around the edges of
the room
so there were a lot of people there at
one time and they all claimed to have
seen
this green light now a few of the people
including frank defilitta the guy who
wrote the book
he was actually there for some of the
sessions and he said and i believe also
one of the photographers said
that sometimes the green light
looked kind of like it was trying to
form into a humanoid
shape all right like they would kind of
see shoulders and
arm musculature and a bald head
things like that no one ever saw any
feet or a face or anything like that but
it just kind of looked like silhouette
like
all right um weird yeah although none of
these were ever captured on
camera but they did get some other photo
anomalies now they weren't captured on
camera they would take
they were taking photos but they would
just nothing show up yeah nothing would
show up or
or it would just show up like just with
strange light anomalies which was
another thing i was gonna
because sometimes doris would say
that the entity was in a particular
place and no one would see it
but when they took a picture of the spot
she said then
something weird would come out on the
photo right like for example
uh there was one point she was sitting
on her bed and she said to the
photographer it's
it's up in the corner of the room and he
took a picture he couldn't see anything
he took a picture up there with his
polaroid
and the polaroid was all almost
completely
whited out so he thought something was
the matter with the camera
so he took another photo of the upper
corner and that was also almost all
white it out
and then he said to doris well tell me
when the entity isn't up there anymore
so she told him when it was gone and
then he took a picture of the same
corner
and it looked normal okay and the same
thing happened later she said
the entity's right in front of my face
he couldn't see it but he took a picture
of her
and she was almost completely whited out
all you can see was like the edge of her
hair
or whatever and same thing happened he
took two pictures they were whited out
then she said okay it's gone took a
picture of her
and the picture was normal okay now
probably the most famous photo
uh from this investigation
is the one and maybe some of you guys
have seen it but it's
it's a black and white photo it's of
doris she's sitting on her bed kind of
with her head down
and right over her head is this really
really bright
arc of light and there's like a littler
arc
up to the left i think now why this is
significant
is because if the light had been because
there was a wall behind doris like you
know the corner of a wall
the one wall and then the other one was
perpendicular
so he said now if this light had been
reflected on the wall
like from a flashlight or whatever then
you know the light would be bent because
because it was in a corner because it's
hitting the corners
but the arc doesn't do that
suggesting that it is floating in space
okay
above her head that it has three
dimensions does it look
three-dimensional when you see the photo
um sort of okay i mean
when you're just looking at it just
casually you're just kind of like what's
just a little bent arc of like yeah it's
pretty big actually and it's like
maybe a foot or two above her head how
wide does it appear to be um
maybe six inches okay so it's small
maybe a little bit actually maybe a
little bit wider okay it's kind of hard
to tell from the photo it's like it's
hard to tell how close to the camera it
is
right okay um and evidently they sent
this picture to
i think it was popular photography
magazine at the time and
this was like i don't know about now i
don't even know if that magazine's still
around but
at the time it was the only quote
unquote ghost photo that they had ever
published because they couldn't uh
determine any fakery present you said
you know if that was a light that was
reflected from somewhere else it should
have
bent right on the wall i saw a photo
from this case also one time it
uh looked like a little ball of light
down by the floor i think it's by the
floor or
uh up against a wall where the wall
meets the floor yeah did you see that or
was it the wall meets the ceiling
yeah it looked like a little ball of
light and it was kind of uh
yeah i think i know it yeah yeah i would
say
about the size of a ping-pong ball and
it was weird-shaped yeah
and you could tell that it was casting
light on the on on the wall
right and that was in the 70s you know
it was kind of before lasers
but it looked like a little glowing ball
huh it's out there you'll see it
yeah yeah there's pictures of this yeah
i don't i
kind of remember it but i looked at so
many pictures from the case and i saw
like a uh there was a little documentary
where the guy was showing the polaroids
well they were saying that occasionally
they'd see little balls of light go
through the air
sideways yeah that's right yeah i had
forgotten about that i think they were
green
yeah like little comets yeah yeah yeah
several yeah several of them reported
that also and these were i mean these
were
supposedly yeah i mean scientists they
were student universities yeah they were
students studying to be
parapsychologists or studying that's
weird it's weird such bizarre claims and
then you have people from
a university going there and confirming
some of it at least yeah which i guess
that i guess this happened there was a
lot of people that were involved in it
that saw it
yeah now more um controversial
are the spirit rape allegations because
as i said the only physical evidence
they had of that was
the bruising um that they found on her
which obviously could have been caused
by
no one actually saw it means other than
the sun
other the kids said they had seen it
happen was it just throwing it around
throwing her around or was it actually
raping her
see that they didn't really say uh the
son said he'd seen her thrown around but
i don't know if he
had never actually seen her being quote
unquote raped or
or if he just didn't want to say it
because that was his mom and right and
ew
you know what i mean so i'm not really
sure like he seemed a little
i'd read one interview with him his name
is brian harris i believe
and there's an interview with him on
online and um
i think it's from a few years ago and he
was saying
you know the movie was pretty accurate
yeah that's what happened he got thrown
back against the wall and things like
that
he was saying now later on there were
some allegations about his mom that were
probably
not true um i think even barry taft the
dr barry taff
said that their house had been condemned
and he said that's [ __ ] that's not
true that's not what happened and uh
some people said that his mom was a
drunk
and you know he said that wasn't really
true either
he said she did drink some after the
[ __ ] started hitting the fan because you
know right
you would if you're being raped by
ghosts
um so so i'm not really sure
where and like i said doris bither
herself seemed uncommunicative
largely she wanted help but she didn't
seem to really want to open up to the
investigators
um which that's not the way she's really
portrayed in the movie
yeah in the movie she's kind of seems a
lot different i mean
you know it does have similarities but
the thing is um
dr taff said he would have really liked
if she had undergone some
psychological testing physical testing
but she didn't but she refused okay all
right
so we have something to hide something
weird maybe which in a way
might have caused a lot of speculation
about her later
right that um one that she was making it
up
two that she was mentally ill or that
she had some kind of strange
psychosexual thing going on with her
just because you're mentally ill
doesn't necessarily mean the phenomenon
isn't happening because people have seen
true that's true you might maybe you're
mentally ill and you manifest
and it manifests it that way which which
is also a possibility
i mean because particularly like i said
she was not a particularly
happy woman she had like a lot of
problems and she'd been abused
for much of her young life so
that might have been evidently so that
might have been coming out in that
particular
way now after the um
after the investigation
i think the well no i was gonna say i
think the rape stopped but i guess they
didn't well according to her they didn't
right um some of the other
some of the other uh phenomena seem to
dissipate somewhat
now the kids kind of moved away they
kind of lost track of their mom
[Music]
in later years she still claimed that
these she called them hitchhikers i
think like spiritual hitchhikers
okay so they were like attached to her
yeah
and she claimed later there are rumors
that
she later claimed that a ghost or one of
these hitchhikers had
impregnated her impregnated her yes okay
and whether and obviously that is not
confirmed there's no hospital anywhere
that said she gave birth to a little
baby that looked like casper or anything
like that
um laughing about it but you know yeah
must have been she must have thought she
got impregnated somehow
yeah there i mean there there is such a
thing as a hysterical pregnancy like if
people believe hard enough that they're
pregnant then they will manifest some of
the
but no child's kind of no obviously
right yeah i've never seen one that
must have been something like that must
have been something like that where it
was like total immaculate conception you
just
imagined a baby and put it in there
anakin skywalker pops out yeah
there was no father
it was just the midichlorian yeah but um
yes let's not talk about that
but uh so at any rate yeah she said
she'd been impregnated by ghosts and
that was kind of sad but evidently she
was bothered by
these uh hitchhikers for the rest of her
life and she died actually quite
young uh she died of pulmonary failure
she i think she was
59. pretty young yeah so she's uh she's
hardly been
dead a while i guess so yeah and it's
it's actually kind of i know we're kind
of like making jokes about casper babies
and stuff like that but
well this was a while ago yeah it is
kind of a sad story yeah
it is kind of a sad story and so
what do we think i mean do we think this
[ __ ] really have much of it really
happened
do we think there's some cause behind it
oh well i think it's just uh
classic poltergeist she you know and if
i don't know it evidently happened you
had a lot of witnesses to it
so i would just say it was classic
poltergeist which is not ghost per se
but it's just a manifestation of psychic
force under the influence of the
subconscious
so i'd say she's probably had a lot of
internal conflicts that she couldn't
express
a lot of pent-up anxieties and i guess
you could say like her
subconscious kind of became astrally
projected if that's what you want to say
and just uh became whatever characters
she needed in order to torment herself
might have been some kind of
manifestation of her own guilt difficult
to say
don't we didn't didn't meet her and we
didn't
have anything to do with the case we
didn't see it we just have to go with
you know what was written what was
reported yeah and i think
i think the case did happen and i think
it happened as described
by the witnesses especially the
university
the the university witnesses i wouldn't
really put
much weight into what um
the poltergeist focus thought of it
that's just the way she imagined it
imagining it as three people
raping her i think she was doing it to
herself
on some weird level
but i think the phenomena happened i
yeah i think i agree with you there yeah
i also
i forgot to mention too that her uh you
know her common thing was
you know was the three entities two
little ones and one big one she called
them
now the children said there was a fourth
one
and they called him mr who's it and
the son not the oldest son but the
middle son
yeah he said that he thought this was
the ghost of his grandfather
weird because apparently he said that's
well that was who it looked like
that would be her dad huh yeah well
that's some weird
that that infers something weird it does
something go down with her and her dad
i don't know yeah that's what i mean
it's like yeah we can speculate we don't
know because like i said
a lot was not she would not give up a
lot of uh she wouldn't divulge a lot of
details about her past
i think the case is real but i don't
think we know enough to draw any
conclusions right
it's just yes but the movie's worth
watching it's just
it's just that the end is ridiculous i
just can't believe i don't
like what like whose rectum did they
pull that out
i mean how why would you even think of
that well it's hollywood they have to
have a big climactic end and it has to
have some element of an
action movie i guess you could say so
yeah i definitely come on
well without that maybe ghostbusters
never would have happened sure
where they were trying to catch ghosts
and put them in boxes and trap ghosts
but still freezing like ghosts don't
cross the lines
i would never think of doing frozen
ghost pudding pops i would never think
of that
that's just like the stupid well even if
if i did think of it i'd be like no
that's [ __ ] dumb
and then i wouldn't do it yeah it's like
the ghost traps on that [ __ ]
redneck that ghost asylum show yeah
that's pretty it's on destination
america where there's like
well let's we're gonna build a ghost
trap and it has [ __ ]
a bug zap or a light in it and then
there's like barbed wire or whatever
or what was the one the funny thing too
is that
we were watching it one day yeah and you
said oh they should make a trap with
like all these mirrors inside so like
the ghost will go in there and it'll be
trapped by all the mirrors yeah just
take a box and on the beard
next episode that was the exact traffic
yeah a box with mirrors on the inside
right he'll go in there he'll be
confused he'll never be able to get out
yeah it'll be like
it'd be like a fun house ghost trap so
yeah that was uh yeah that's just a
comedy show
they're super super rednecky i mean like
they're more rednecky than anybody
all these ghost programs on uh
on cable have just really gone downhill
they just run out of
i mean there's so many of them
destination america there's that's
pretty much the whole
ghost channel i don't think i ever seen
normal shows on it didn't i used to have
like travel shows they used to
but uh hey you know they got rednecks
catching ghosts so you know people would
rather watch that i mean he watches tv
no that's true you know
hardly i do kind of like ghost brothers
though i gotta say yeah ghost brothers
was funny because at least they're
self-aware
yeah and that they're being funny the
best one was a haunting that
the first three seasons after that
and paranormal witness was okay for what
two seasons the private season and then
season one and
they all start going downhill well they
started getting ludicrous after a while
it's almost like they kind of had to top
themselves from the previous seasons
they're like hey we're gonna put
werewolves in this one and they hype the
cases yeah
you know uh the person will say one
thing and then what they what they show
on the screen
how it's portrayed is totally different
here's what bothers me about that
yeah here's what bothers me about that
it's like yeah they'll have the person
interviewing and they'll say
oh you know i felt really weird like the
hair stood up on the back of my neck
right and on the
d on the reconstruction they'll show the
ghost they'll show the ghost like behind
them
yeah like the person like they didn't
say they saw that right
i'm like just don't make it so obvious
you know what i mean if you guys
if you guys hear a weird whistling sound
that's not ghost that's me vaping
oh you ruined it you should have just
said what was that
yeah they'll have comments what is that
strange noise back there
yeah we could have had like a whole
conspiracy thing about that going on
that's just me inhaling oh man yeah oh
well now you ruined it okay this
is uh i think we're pretty much done
with the entity right yeah i think we
kind of discussed that if anybody's
listening to that is interested or has
any other
information about it um it'll it'll be
like a very small section in my
next book that's coming out yeah among
there'll be a bunch of other yeah
there's like a ton of other like 50
other cases in there too but
it's just one of the ones but it was
like i said it was the only ghost rape
one that i could find
and nobody write me with ghost rape
stories i don't believe you okay
i don't believe that's funny okay next
on the list
is uh shiny yes and this is one of my
favorite
topics to talk about because we talk
about this
all the time and we just like go on and
on about it because it's just so
fascinating we've seen the shining of
millions
we've seen the shining a million times
and we've had this and here's the cool
thing and
so i don't know you guys remember like a
few years ago this
documentary came out called room 237 and
it was about
all the i don't know if it was like so
much the most common or the craziest
conspiracy theories about the shiny
because there's a lot of those there's
like a whole wiki
yeah of conspiracy theories there's a
whole their their whole youtube channels
deca
dedicated to analyzing a single scene
right now i have to say like i'm really
interested in
these conspiracy theories that people
come up with but i think
75 of them are largely [ __ ] because
it seems to me that a lot of the most
common ones like for example
it was stanley kubrick's guilt over
faking the moon landing yeah
um moon landing yeah which whatever
don't tell buzz aldrin yeah yeah
right in the tank yeah but funny
but things like like that conspiracy
which is probably the most common one
that people think of when they think of
shine against barissies and
the one where it's about the holocaust
which i don't get that at all
no i don't think this has anything to do
with that because here's the thing the
moon landing one
what is the evidence that people give
for that okay the apollo
the sweater the sweater that danny has
on and
what else that's it right uh if i
remember correctly it had something to
do with it it wasn't it didn't have
something to do with numerology also in
that in that scene
you could pick that scene apart and you
could you could write right now
i'm not saying that there's not some
kind there must be some kind of
significance with the numbers because he
did
reuse the numbers 12 and 42 like a bunch
of times
so that's going to mean something what
it means i don't know but
but and also the and that kind of
relates back to the
the world war ii holocaust one which
like i said it seems to me that the only
uh the only evidence for that is one he
has a german
typewriter and two the number 42
reappears all the time
which 1942 that was the first year the
final solution
that seems like a stretch no now
there has to be something significant
about the number 42 though because
kubrick changed the number of the scary
dead woman room
to two three seven in the book it was
two
one seven now two plus three plus seven
is forty-two
and now i don't know if this is true or
not but i've seen other places
what is it two plus three two plus three
plus seven
is this or two times three yeah it's not
it's i don't know it comes it's two
times so you have to deny you have to
you have to multiply that's two yeah
it's two times three yeah
[Laughter]
that's what i meant yeah okay just
that's what i meant
and i've also seen on the internet that
people said oh there were 42 cars in the
parking lot
the number 42 like appears on i don't
remember exactly
a license plate you see i don't know
i've just seen other people say that and
we saw the movie not too long ago but i
wasn't looking
i don't remember i don't remember a shot
of the parking lot
i think there was when they first got
there or when everyone was leaving
because you know they got there like on
the last day when everyone was leaving
okay i don't know so i don't know if
that's the case or not but but there is
some kind of 42 thing and there's
probably like a 12 thing also
but i don't know if that is it now the
reason we wanted to talk about this was
because
tom here came up with kind of a cool
like overarching thematic
thrust that i don't think i've ever seen
laid out quite in the same way that you
laid it out
okay like i've seen aspects of it talked
about
um on other in other places
but i think you kind of tied it all
together in a way that
it hasn't been done before i don't think
i don't i've never really well i guess
i'm impressed with myself because i
didn't know
you're a president i didn't know that
maybe i saw something that other people
didn't see
yeah but and i'm not saying that people
didn't come up with like aspects of it
because there's like a lot of little
threads
and i've seen a lot of people have these
little threads
but not the whole like tapestry that you
kind of made out of it
you're right well where do you want me
to start well let's first let's start
with okay the most comm
one of the most common conspiracy
theories and one that i think is not
[ __ ]
is the people that say uh it's kubrick's
um it's the meaning of it it has to do
with the native american
the genocide of the native americans by
the europeans
which yeah this is the one that is the
least bullshitty to me
because obviously the overlook hotel is
decorated
with a native american motif
um allman says to tells the family at
the beginning
that uh native american tribes had to be
quote unquote repelled
when they were first building the hotel
because there were a lot of uh attacks
by the tribes uh that were having their
land uh
in imprisonment yeah yeah so
was it the difference the difference
between what i think it is and what i've
heard people
say about native american genesis i
don't think it's actually referring to a
genocide
it just refers to the native americans
and to tribalism
and to and to the nature of man and the
nature of men
and to almost like a paganism in general
yeah
right um you know so
so we have that aspect which like i said
you know
there's all the native american stuff in
the you know some of wendy's outfits
or have kind of have native american
themes there's all those shots of like
the calimet
baking powder baking soda whatever it is
with the with the indian headdress the
native american headdress on the can and
sometimes
sometimes you can see the the the labels
very well yeah when truth is being
spoken
yeah and when later on when lies are
being spoken they're turned around so
you can't quite
see all the faces okay see i never use
that yeah because when
well i'm kind of getting ahead of myself
when the house
is talking okay when halloran
is talking to uh dan danny
in the background you see the cans and
when their first meeting
when halloran first meets danny in the
background you see all the labels of the
cans
okay so he's making peace with them that
you can trust him later on
when grady
was it grady yeah talking talking to
jack
while he was locked in the pantry and
he's talking to him
about getting out of there and killing
his family you see that they're all
turned in different directions so you
never can't quite see which i
which i interpreted that as meaning uh
deception
yeah well because like we said before i
don't know if you guys know but that is
an actual it's baking powder right it's
baking
yeah calumet is the brand name and that
i think that means piece pipe
piece pipe or peace agreement something
yeah um
so and obviously that was significant
because i you know i don't know if you
guys know but the
you know the out the exteriors of the
outlook that's a real
hotel it's in colorado i've seen it but
the interiors were all
shot on a set um built
i assume to kubrick's specifications so
you know it's decorated the way
he wanted it and uh going back to what
we're saying about the native american
decoration
in the in the hotel which actually
almond points out to the family it's
like yeah this is from local tribes
around here they made all this stuff
um also the supposedly the ones that
were repelled
yeah so it's like yeah then we took all
their [ __ ] and put it and splashed it
all over the walls
like like you do and uh but i was gonna
say it's also kind of significant you
know
with this overarching theory that the
main
hall it's not a ballroom it's the main
hall where jack sets his
typewriter up right which what is that
it's like the
it's like a big lobby i guess yeah it's
a lobby okay yeah because the desks and
stuff are down the hall
so it's the big lobby where he puts the
table
and the typewriter almost in the place
where like the altar would be if that
was a cathedral
right and in the overhead shots it looks
like a cathedral right
well let me let me uh explain
what i think it is okay and then and
then we'll kind of go back a little
details you know
okay what i think it is is i think the
hotel
was founded as
a getaway and retreat
for hedonism basically a bunch of
pleasure a bunch of violence a bunch of
animal
uh what's good animal instincts and
animal drives urges
urges and things so it's it's a temple
basically
uh they consecrate the ground with uh
human blood because we assume that
during when they were repelling
the indians that there were casualties
yes so that consecrated it
then they build this temple to pleasure
and hedonism and all the
animalistic animalistic stuff then they
uh
co-opt all the tribal motifs of their
enemies and uh decorate the place
with that and uh then
a bunch of murders happen a bunch of uh
yeah
a bunch of bad deals happen and uh
it kind of creates a life of its own uh
well how
how is it that i put it before it's like
um
uh help me out here well it's almost
it's almost like a sacrificial temple
yeah
and we'll kind of go into like all of
the stuff that makes us think this yeah
but it almost seems like and and i don't
think that whoever built the hotel was
doing this necessarily on purpose
no just it just happened like a big ball
it's almost like
i think the way and when we were talking
about this before
we're like you know how um the satanic
black mass quote unquote whenever they
show that it's almost like an inversion
of christianity like they have
upside-down crosses and
they have like an altar yeah with the
you know so
this is almost like the
elite you know the people at the top
echelons of society
right basically inverting
the pagan traditions yeah well it's
almost kind of like that there's no
difference between
yeah the tribe at the top of the uh
civilization and an alien tribe that's
considered to be at the bottom of the
civilization right that they're all the
same
they're co-opting their savagery yeah
that they're all savages really
right okay while still kind of thinking
of themselves as better as the battery
it's all the best people come here yeah
you know allman said that exactly
right which were gangsters and
politicians and
you know basically the guys at the top
the one percenters the
shitty people the new world order
whatever you want to call them
illuminati
you know right we were into all that and
that there was just
that it's just another tribe another
tribe of savages
right that's basically how i interpreted
it
now there was some native american
motifs
in um shelly duvall's um
yeah clothing clothing where she kind of
looked like she was dressed up a little
bit like a native american
yeah and then you have this uh her
husband this white guy chasing her
around with an axe
yeah you know and there was a lot of
bull motifs
and that's another that just occurred to
me in the book
it wasn't an axe it was a mallet it was
a mountain
yeah so kubrick changed that too
yeah and you have and then you you have
a lot of uh
bull motifs you have a thesis and
theseus motif with the maze the
minotaurs which was also changed from
the book because in the book obviously
it was hedge animals which was
changed to amaze which the story of the
minotaurs is a story of child sacrifice
exactly he's gonna sacrifice his own
child
yes all right so its soul can join in
with all these dark souls
that are partying hard in another
spiritual dimension
yeah all the people that were murdered
or wanted to stay there after they died
yeah they're all still there right it's
their version of head of heaven
right but it might be considered a hell
yeah
and when the murders are getting ready
to happen you hear them all chanting
in the background i don't know if you
catch it with the music but they're back
there chanting like a
satanic chant that a human sacrifice is
going to go down
everything's a sacrifice yeah you know
everyone you know and like i said i had
not noticed the chanting until you
pointed it out where
i think the the point in the movie where
it's the most obvious
is when you see like right after danny
has gone out the
bathroom window and run into the maze
and shelly is running around that oh
shelly i call her
wendy that's her character's name when
she's running around the the hotel with
the knife
and right before she sees uh the the
dog bear [ __ ] thing with the tuxedo
yeah right before she sees that there's
a really really loud like
chanting on the soundtrack like right
before she sees that
yeah well they got a guy in a tux get
getting blown by a guy dressed up as a
dog
yeah even though i thought it was better
and that's just that that's a good
symbolism you know of uh
people that have no limits and that
animal and man are one in the same
one and you know and that that's the
little dimension that they went off in
you know hedonistic party land right so
basically it's almost like like the
overlook hotel could be seen
as kind of almost like a temple of black
magic yeah
or sex magic sacrificial magic and
violence
yes remember there's murder and stuff
going on in there and suicide
that takes infusions of blood and people
that drank themselves to death and
people you know
stuff like that yeah it would i would
consider it to be like
uh kind of like the sith temple
where luke skywalker
confronted himself and found darth vader
behind
the uh found him found darth vader in
there and then found his face behind the
mask of vader
in paris empire strikes back yeah so
it'd be a place like that on dagobah
yeah it's a place of evil right yeah and
like most of the evils happening in the
spirit world and yeah some of that's
trying to pull living people to pull
living people there
it's psychic energy yeah and because
like i said there's the very significant
uh moment in the film
you know right before [ __ ] starts to get
weird
is jack nicholson walking into the gold
ballroom going up to the bar
and saying to himself i'd give my soul
for a drink or yeah even just a beer or
something like a glass of beer
even just a glass of beer and then
suddenly lloyd appears behind the bar
yeah it's about selling your soul
too yeah it's it's faustian without you
exactly
so that's why i think there's kind of a
whole i think that
you know not necessarily hell in the cr
in the judeo-christian sense but
hell in the sense of uh i don't know
it's it's i
feel like it's kind of well he sold his
soul for a beer
yeah in exchange for sacrifice in his
son
even though and this isn't really gone
into in the movie
as much as it is in the book the hotel
didn't actually want jack
it wanted danny right because danny was
powerful
yeah jack jack thought it wanted the
hotel made him think that it wanted him
because he was weak and he could be
manipulated right because he was a drunk
right so they knew that by kind of
kissing his ass and
right giving him what he wanted and
giving him what he wanted right then he
would bring them
what they wanted which was danny which i
guess is the same thing that happened to
grady
yes because grady grady killed his
killed his children also
right and that's why it's significant
that danny keeps seeing that because
those were like the last
child sacrifices and his his reward was
just to be
a a waiter in the other dimension
yeah so he kind of got [ __ ] yeah yeah
and actually i didn't
that didn't occur to me until you just
mentioned it he just became a servant
yeah he was just a servant of
yeah of this hotel well which i guess
was lloyd also because he was just a
bartender right i think the lawyer but i
think
lloyd face of the hotel yeah i think
lloyd represented
that was the main spirit of the hotel
yeah he was like their spokesman
right i think he was i think he was the
collective face
of the hotel because he was the one that
was serving jack
drinks he was the one giving jack what
he wanted well you know
he had to read the book too and in the
book it makes it more clear that he's
that he's the main figure behind the
hotel right
and he may be the hotel if i remember
yeah long time but i've seen it i do
kind of like that i do kind of like that
revelation about grady though that they
they just made it but i'm sure they did
the same thing to him they they were
like yeah you're the man and all this
other stuff now kill your kids now [ __ ]
you now you're a waiter forever
yeah you don't even get to like party
with all these other cool people out
there no because they were rich
evidently they were rich and they were
gangsters and leaders and stuff yourself
as their servants
he was just taking care of the place in
the off season anyway
when he got killed right he wasn't of
the same standing but the
based on the motifs and everything and
the story as it goes
it leads me to believe that the message
of the story is no matter
how much money you have and how much
success you have you're still just an
animal
yeah no matter how exalted you are right
or how much you think of yourself
and that and evidently these people knew
that these souls knew that and embraced
that because there's there's a lot of
animal imagery and a lot of uh
savagery imagery you know what i'm
talking about and
uh bull imagery and minotaur and all
that stuff's there so
there were people that had embraced the
animal side
yes and then they wanted to live that in
the afterlife
yeah and i don't know
i think that was kind of kubrick's i
think he brought that to the movies
there wasn't really much of that in the
book that wasn't in the book the book
the book was mostly and it's actually my
favorite stephen king book of all the
books he's ever written
and even the book didn't have
that same mythic
good versus evil kind of quality i think
the book was just kind of more about
a haunted house yeah that wanted
danny's energy and was using his drunk
dead
to get it so it was kind of more
contained
within the family and the family was
just trying to get energy i don't think
i mean and i just i read the book maybe
what it like a year and a half ago
something like that
i don't i didn't really get the sense of
this grand
mythic you know animal versus human
paganistic kind of motif
kubrick uh you know in his other movies
he always likes
he's into the uh the illuminati uh type
conspiracies
at the very top being big and kind of
evil
yeah yeah yeah like eyes wide shut yeah
same kind of theme
i think basically what he's saying is
the people at the very top are just a
different interpretation of the people
at the very bottom
yeah they're yeah they know better than
that yeah yeah so
even though they're perceived as better
than they're right in some ways they're
worse i
i kind of got the impression from the
shining that he thought they were worse
than yeah than the original pagans who
had who'd been on the ground who
who these elites were they perceived
them as savage but they also kind of
wanted to be them
yeah well i think they're saying that
the people that the people at the top
that wanted to be like that recognize
the fact that there wasn't much
difference
yeah that there you that that these uh
tribal warriors had strengths that
they wanted that they admired right so
it's not like they were decorating and
maybe
freedoms also the freedoms right exactly
so it's not like they're
it's not like they're decorating the
inside of the hotel
to uh to diminish the native americans
they're honoring them they're honoring
their
uh oneness with nature and the animal
kingdom and
freedoms and things yeah yeah sure
because that was another significant
and i think we forgot to mention this at
the beginning instead of them being pent
up they could be like the
indians yeah free laws to themselves
right basically yeah yeah that's a good
way of putting it actually their own
little tribe
and like i said i don't think um i mean
the book
you know the book didn't really go into
a lot of that
um i don't think like i said it happened
that way no and i think that's probably
why he didn't like
kubrick's adaptation probably too deep
yeah or he thought that he took his
story and did something with it that he
didn't intend
well what you see what you see from the
kubrick version of the movie is you see
um uh what it would have
looked like if you couldn't see what was
happening in the spirit world of the
book
right about because a lot of stuff that
happened in the book was happening in
this in a in a realm of ghosts yes a lot
of it yeah
so if
you were there at the overlook and
weren't seeing the ghosts
you would have seen it go down pretty
much like you saw like you saw in the
movie right
which is exactly what i liked about
kubrick's version now i don't have a
problem with the book because
here's the thing and i i talk about this
a lot like on my blog and other places
and
stephen king uh his books are generally
very good but in a book
you can get away with [ __ ] you can't get
away with in a movie
because when you write a book and i
should know because i write some
you have you have to create an entire
world
in a reader's mind right so you have to
describe
everything you have to describe what
people are thinking you have to describe
what everything looks
like um you know you don't have any
visuals
right you have to make people have
visuals in a movie
you have visuals so you can't
i don't know you can't put everything
literally
up on the screen like you can in a book
and i think that that's
stephen king's weakness yeah is that he
doesn't understand they're two
completely
different mediums and they have to be
approached in two completely different
ways and
you can really see this in whenever was
it 1997
that they made that miniseries that
stephen king directed
and he adapted it for the screen and he
directed it
and it sucked well you thought it sucked
i thought it was okay well you got a
movie it wasn't as good as the movie
yeah i mean it wouldn't
it was different it was like the book it
was almost the book verbatim
right and they added a really bad ending
to it
yeah remember how the ending you know
where he's uh or daddy see
danny scene sees his dad again after
he's
dead yeah that's right blowing him
kisses it was really
[ __ ] bad yeah that wasn't even in the
book that was not in the book they just
added that [ __ ] and it was
made it really hokey terrible ending
scene
well and the problem too and i did not
like uh
the end where he where it looked like he
was fighting with the ghosts over the
boiler
controls do you remember that yeah and
that didn't actually
happen which didn't happen in the book
also here's here's the problem the
the stephen king miniseries that they
made they tried to redeem the father
yes and that's not what went down in the
book no the father got consumed
by it yeah he was trying to to release
the pressure off the
off the boiler yeah but he was possessed
i think at that point wouldn't he
yeah although i think he was fighting it
but i think he got killed anyway right
so the whole
at the end of the book the whole hotel
blew up right yeah it blew up which it
did in the mini series also
right and like i said i think the
problem with the mini series
is exactly what you said it's he
basically just took the book and put it
pretty literally
yeah up on the screen now
one the ghosts in the miniseries looked
like ghosts they had like scary monster
making yeah
um also at the beginning of the mini
series
the guy when jack is first taking the
tour of the hotel
um the guy that's showing him the boiler
and how it works and everything like
that
just has this whole shitload of
exposition
telling them all these horrible things
yeah which happened
and i think that was well in the book it
worked
yeah but you can get away with it don't
do exposition in a movie show don't tell
that's one of the the cool thing about
kubrick's
is that you have no [ __ ] idea what's
going on that's what makes it scary
that's what i mean like it's kind of
hinted that some bad [ __ ] might happen
at the hotel but nothing
concrete almond doesn't say oh these
gangsters were in this person got
murdered and that person got murdered
the only time you know is when halloran
says to danny don't go in room 237
right he doesn't even tell danny what
happened in there right you don't know
what happened in there
i i remember what it was like when i was
a kid the first time i saw
the shiny and the part where uh
scat man crothers you know hallerin
turns to danny
and looks at him and you hear that
crescendo of
weird uh chanting was it chanting or was
it music
yeah it builds up and then it goes and
then you hear the voice
you want some ice cream doc yeah
remember that and i was like whoa what's
that
you know yeah and that was and because
it wasn't explained
what the shining was that had a lot of
impact
yeah and in the book they had already
kind of blown
uh blown the secret of what this you
know they've already explained to you
basically psychic ability right it's a
psychic ability you could do a lot of
stuff with it is the force basically
yeah because danny knew what was gonna
happen he knew that the hotel was scary
before he got there and
he had the you know but that was very
effective in a movie not to
expect that yeah where you know and
speaking of danny's
uh psychic ability i also really liked
like in the mini series
now and in the book also danny actually
saw tony
didn't he yeah i think he did sometimes
he saw him or herself
and when they put that in the mini
series that was hokey as [ __ ]
it didn't look right like oh there's
this nerdy guy
floating by this street sign yeah and
i'm like that just what
the the way that kubrick did it was so
elegant
you know what i mean with him talking in
a different voice with his little finger
because that's what a kid would do yeah
and you don't know if the kid's nuts or
what
right and i think that ambiguity was
much better like you don't know if the
kid's just crazy or if you have
something wrong with his brain like that
makes him have a
split personality or if he really it's
classic movie though
i'll tell you what that original the
original shiny was just
fantastic we i must have seen it a
million times on cable back in hbo
i was a kid when i was a kid that was
scary as crap i think the first time i
was on you couldn't stop watching this
you had to watch it over and over now
another thing we were talking about when
we talked about this before was
now in the book halloran doesn't die no
he doesn't die
and now and i do and i like that
character
yeah and you were saying that you didn't
really like it that halloran got killed
in the kubrick movie but or got
killed so quickly i mean i don't like
that but
i just used him as a mechanism to
deliver the snow cat
that was their way out pretty much and i
thought that he should have done a
little bit more before he got killed
[Music]
somebody had to die yeah there's a
horror movie somebody i can see why
kubrick made that decision and to me
i kind of like that because one it kind
of subverted a lot of the horror movie
tropes like oh
the guy saved the day just in the nick
of time right yeah you know what i mean
because shows up and instantly kills
yeah because here's what happened like
you're kind of struggling with halloran
the whole time and it's like you know he
can hear
danny from miami like he can hear him
from across the country he hears him
and he's like i gotta get on a plane and
he gets on plane and then he gets there
and he has to run a snow cat and all the
roads are closed
and he's like struggling to get up i
gotta get up there and
i gotta get up there and then he gets
there and he walks in the door and he's
like hey where is everybody and then
whack yeah and to me that was terrifying
yeah because i was like this whole movie
that poor guy has been trying to get up
there and he's going to help him he's
going to
and then no just killed he just walks in
the door and then jack is there with the
[ __ ]
well he attacks and he's just like
digging into his stomach and i was like
oh man
well he did he did save him he gave his
life to bring him the snow cat
true without that they couldn't that
probably wasn't what he intended no but
that's what
happened and in a way that's what made
it so scary because
i mean halloran had the shining too yeah
yeah he was psychic also
and it just kind of go to show how
powerful the hotel was
yeah that even though he had these
abilities
like he couldn't do anything stop it
weird you know what i mean like you know
like you said he helped him in the end
like by getting the snow cat up there
and they escaped in that but
but the fact that he couldn't help them
get out
you know to me that was very scary that
was very scary yeah
and um you know and i think we were
talking to last night how
kubrick's uh we we liked that kubrick's
ghosts looked like just the regular
people yeah i mean other than the
rotting corpse lady but she was a dead
lady so you know she looked like a
corpse
and she didn't like that was yeah she
looked normal at the beginning
well she looked dead and she looked dead
in the uh bathtub
yeah and then she looked dead when he
looked looked at her
back in the mirror yeah but to him she
looked normal
and i think that was that was kind of a
better decision one they didn't show a
lot of
ghosts or they weren't obvious ghosts
right they just look like
regular people they showed uh the
ballroom filled with skeletons
true that was right at the very end yeah
and uh wendy saw that
right wendy just saw that that was
almost kind of like at the end when the
hotel was like yeah that's right i'm
haunted
everybody can see it now they were in
the elevator it's a party yeah
because she didn't really see it until
the very end until the very end
oh and she saw that guy with his head
yeah well he was the one that was saying
it's a party yeah
yeah so she didn't really see anything
until the end when she saw the [ __ ]
guy and stuff like that
but uh which you know i can see how that
that
scene it's so brief but it's really well
done like the way she's looking down the
hall and there's that door
yeah and then all of a sudden that guy
gets up and turns and you're like what
the [ __ ]
because you know furries 30s furries
yeah and you have no idea
the back story or anything and that see
that's what made it so creepy to me
because they're just like who the [ __ ]
is that what's going on
that's what it would have been like you
know if you didn't know
what the ghosts were doing like when you
read the book that's what she sees
see and that's what i mean she doesn't
even know who that is you know who that
is
right yeah and in a way like i said in
the book it works the book is very scary
i remember
being scared by the book but a movie is
something different you can't
you have to just show things you can't
explain things
um or it makes things much less scary i
think the shining is so scary it because
you don't
know i mean if you haven't read the book
you wouldn't know who all those people
are you wouldn't know who that lady in
the tub was
in the book you do because you know what
happened but um
in that room yeah but in the movie
you're just like what the [ __ ] is going
on like
and that's exactly what it would be like
if you were there
yeah which i think makes it much scarier
because it's relatable
is there anything else about the shining
we got to mention um i think we kind of
so basically basically black magic
temple oh i wanted to say something
about the baphomet thing i know you
think that's [ __ ] yeah i think it's
[ __ ] but um
but it could be i mean kubrick was very
detail-oriented oh and we also have to
talk about the weird uh geometry
okay well yeah mention that okay so
first i'm going to talk about the
baphomet thing
uh we got into this uh earlier because
um of the black magic thing
now you know obviously if you'll
remember the iconic final scene of the
film where they do the close-up on the
black and white photograph from a new
year's party in 1924 and jack nicholson
is in the front of the crowd
you know saying that he's always been
there and blah blah
but in that photo he's holding his hands
in kind of a strange position like one
of them
is raised above his head and the other
one is kind of down to his side yeah and
it looks like a famous drawing of
which recalls the famous drawing of the
baphomet
which could tie in with the whole now
i'm not sure
i think it's [ __ ] but i've heard
that this that photograph is actually a
real photograph
that they put is super important his
face is just superimposed over it and
so i don't know so which means that jack
nicholson was not posed in that way for
that picture
i don't know if that's true or not i
don't know if he posed that picture
and then or if he just found an old
picture from that era i think it's an
old picture from that era they just so
he didn't pose him that way
but he might have chosen that photo
because of that hand
thing but like i said that's a stretch
yeah it's a stretch and you can say that
about anything
that's true i don't think anything to do
with the back of it
now one thing although if it did if it
was accidental
then that would be kind of cool because
if if the whole
pagan [ __ ] was uh okay in the very
beginning what's the name of that what's
name the manager of the hotel oh man
okay when they walk in the camera
follows jack torrance as he walks from
the um the lobby the lobby
yeah to allman's office right
the camera follows him the whole time he
makes different turns and when he gets
to olman's office
allman's there in the office and behind
him is a window to the outside
and that's an impossible window that
there could not be a shot of the outside
from that front from from that room
which uh
that it's weird i don't think that was
by accident i think that was put in
there to give you a sense of
unease because i remember being a kid
feeling that something was wrong
but not being able to put your finger on
it right couldn't put my finger on her
it's like it was subliminal and like i
said
if if kubrick did that and it wouldn't
surprise me because he was known for
doing that kind of
crazy [ __ ] um then he's a [ __ ] genius
because i love that kind of stuff that
something in the movie is like
unsettling you but you don't know what
it is so it's almost like it's
subverting your consciousness
right and going right for your
subconscious and there's and you don't
know why
all the interior shots of the hotel are
done on a set
yeah and that whole set was built and uh
online
they showed a uh layout of that yeah
like a like a floor plan
a floor plan of it and you can plainly
see that there could not be
a window to the outside with where that
office it's an impossible it's an
impossible route i think it was
it was a fake it was a fake outside shot
yeah it was uh it had curtains there was
a light there and there was a backdrop
behind it to
look like it was a you could see outside
but it wasn't i was probably only a few
feet deep
yeah yeah and actually there were some
other [ __ ] like that too where
some of the because you know the
hallways are very twisting like a maze
which again is another callback to the
whole theseus and the metaphor
type of thing um legend which what like
we said had to do with child sacrifice
but also there there was a there was a
you know during the last scene where
where jack is chasing danny
through the maze there's kind of a
callback to theseus where instead of a
golden thread he's using his footsteps
right you know to get back out
and also as as jack chases him he gets
less and less
human-like like he's the way he's
walking he's starting to stagger
and he's starting to growl and like his
words are becoming indistinct and
yeah so it's almost like he's a monster
like chasing so he's a minotaur
yeah so he kind of becomes the minotaur
like i said which kind of ties back into
the whole
pagan quote-unquote savage versus
a civilized type of theme that i think
kind of the greeks were both
exactly they were both exact so uh you
know so there was a lot of that going on
there too and i think there was
you know when we were talking about the
geometry which doesn't really have
anything to do with the pagan ship but
it's just kind of a cool
little detail regardless i yeah if you
if you go online i think there's a video
somewhere and there's they show like a
floor plan someone is actually
with a lot of time on their hands has
drawn a floor plan of the overlook hotel
the inside of the set and you can see
that there are hallways where there
should not be hallways
and you know just just all kind of weird
[ __ ] that
was i guess done on purpose like to
unsettle you
yeah but so that was kind of our uh
that was kind of our theory about the
whole entire
theme of the shining and i guess that'll
probably
yeah do it for our topic wrap it up
today so we can wrap up
our show and we'll be back next week
with a couple more um do we do we have
anything on the list
what do you want to do next week oh my
gosh we could do uh
man don't put me on the spot like that i
don't think i have my list yeah we'll
worry about it you guys will know when
we get ready yeah we'll do
paranormal stuff we can do like some
cool like unsolved mysteries
just the kind of usual stuff that we're
going to be doing we'll have guests
every now and then depending on the
depending on who we can get that's good
uh we we
already know a bunch of people that can
come on that are pretty cool but
parapsychologists and stuff like that
that we've worked with in the past
check out jenny's books um she's got a
new one coming out
that's untitled uh one that just came
out
last week called house of fire and
whispers
about uh keith linder's house yeah it
was investigated that was showing demons
in seattle yeah demons in seattle and
that was shown on what was the name of
that
uh program it was ghost adventure ghost
adventures
right and they didn't handle that case
correctly
actually and uh steve mara got some
evidence there a bunch of
avps and evps um but uh
i guess we'll just sign out for now yeah
probably
and uh don't forget putting up a
facebook page check out our facebook
check out our twitter
check out my amazon yeah the facebook
our facebook
uh excuse me not facebook see me our
youtube show
uh we'll have videos with this in other
words our
uh visuals that's what i meant yeah
we're gonna post photos of what we're
talking about
and that'll be up to you and uh and also
check out my blog
if you want to it's goddess of
hellfire.com and i
talk about a lot of movies some of the
stuff we've discussed about the shining
there are a couple articles about that
on there if you want to read it
in more depth than just us blabbering
about it and
i have a bunch of stuff about old movies
new movies all kind of stuff and uh
books too so if you want to check that
out you can and i guess that'll do it
for
our first episode wow neat yeah bye-bye
bye
[Music]
you